Do you recommend certain supplements to take along with full fox chemo?
We have read that burberry and animisinin have synergistic effects.
We are also planning to do IV vitamin C and ALA pre and post chemo.
All of those things are good.
The only thing that I would be careful with with the full fox chemo is an IV chemo
is to follow the chemo protocol that's on our blog post again.
We look up chemo protocols and a good paid man paid and you'll see about doing a fast before chemo
stayed off of your antioxidant type nutrition for the 48 hours.
You can do that always with a IV chemo doing a fast prior to it and state of
antioxidative supplements for 48 hours so that the chemo will work better.
Burberry and animisinin aren't typically classified as antioxidants.
They will help synergistically work with any chemo.
Really any of your immune supplements are going to help with chemo synergistically working better
because it just helps your immune system attack chemo.
Same thing with doctors with chemo but with immutal therapy.